よろしくお願いします
クー イマン パタウィン ヴィジェッサティ
ヤマ ロカンチャ イマン サデーワカン
クー ダンマ パダン スデシタン
クサロ プッパ ミワ パチェッサティ
クー イマン パタウィン ヴィジェッサティ
ヤマ ロカンチャ イマン サデーワカン
クー ダンマ パダン スデシタン
クサロ プッパ ミワ パチェッサティ
で これは質問するところで
次四十五番目はその質問に答えるところです
この第四章というのは
名前はプッパワッガという名前で
プッパというのは花ですね
花の章ということで 別にタイトルにはそんなに意味があるということではございません
ただ まとめてる仏教の中にも花という言葉が出ている
ただそれだけのことで章の名前を付けているんです
そういう 俗世間でものすごい大事に考えるところは
仏教は全くも気にしないで無視しているんです
現代知識社会では タイトルというのは大変な大事な重要なところで
すごい苦労するんですね
仏教はもう何でもいいんだから何か付けておけというぐらいの話なんです
なぜ知識人の社会でこのそんなにタイトルやらね
小さな項目にすごい気にするのかと
結局本の名前読んだだけで名前のタイトルなかったら分かったような気がするんですね
ちょっと開けてみて 英語だったら contents と言うんですけど
このリストがありますね
第一章はこれこれ 二章はこれこれとかね
それちょっと斜めに目を閉じて
はい 分かったぞというね
そういうこのインスタント主義で
本文はそんなに真剣 真面目に読むことはしないんです
仏教の場合はそちらの逆で
もうタイトルのリストを読んでも何一つもわからないんです
ただ何か付けておくだけ
本文読んでみろということなんです
噛み砕いてゆっくりと
ですから この思考パターンというのは
現代人の思考とは随分正反対だと思った方がよろしいと思います
いい得点があります 思うことで
わからないのは当たり前だと
それで自分のメンツはなんとか保たれます
ブッダとその当時の弟子たちの考え方はハチャメチャやと
タイトルぐらい真面目に付けたらどうですかと
そういう風に言ってる人いますね
全然学問的な知識がなかったとかね
分析能力とかね 全然なかったとかね
という風に言ってる偉い知識人たちもいますけどね
そういうわけで 経典の中のタイトルにそんなに拘る必要はない
ただ それなりにまとめるために何か名前を付けてるだけ
しかし この場合はこの花という言葉がいろいろ偈には出てきます
意味は皆様はご存知だと思いますけど
この四十四番目の 一応
私も自分なりの間違ってる意味は言いますけど
コーイマンパテウィンウィジェッサティ
コー誰かがイマンパテウィンこの地球をウィジェッサティっていうのは勝ち取ることなんですね
だから地球王というのはパーリ語の直訳になるとそうなりますけど
誰かがこの地球に勝てるのかと
で それで地球に勝てるって意味がないんですけどね
やっぱり パテウィンというのは
まあ世界っていうことでもよろしいし
それどんな意味でしょうかと
世界に勝ちましたと 地球に勝ちましたっていうことは
皆様が使っている単語で言えば世界征服制覇でしたっけ？よく漫画なんかに出てくる
アニメーションなんかに出てくる言葉で
いつでも世界征服することで
エイリアンの映画であっても
とにかく人類を征服するという
よくある考え方なんですね
世界制覇しようとするのは
これはもうかなり精神的な病気でしょうし
しかし 病気でもみんな病気だったら病気じゃないんですから
今 ごく一般的な当たり前の映画やら漫画やらそちらのメインテーマになっているんです
それでだいたい日本の子供たちなんかは
それはそれで漫画だけで大人になってくると止まる時もありますけど
大人になってもウルトラマンの不安でいる人もいないわけでもないんですけどね
ウルトラマンもかなり今も人気ありますからね
アトムでしたっけ   それはまあ妄想世界でよっぽど病気ってことなんですけど
これは真剣真面目にやろうとする人々もいます
世界制覇しようと で そういうことで
やっぱりブッダの時代でもその概念があったでしょうね
だからブッダに聞くんです
この世界制覇するのは誰ですかと
しかし パテウィンといえば地球なんですけど
本当に仏教的な意味をとるならば
これはすべての生命を乗り越えて打ち勝つことなんです
単なる地球のことじゃないんです
まあなんか ブッダゴーサ長老がその意味は取ってないみたいですけど
それで 1 行で言っているのは
この世界は誰が制覇するのかということで
だから世界生命と ならばね
楼観という言葉は一般的なんですけど
それは使ってないんです
パテリというこの土ですね
地球のという言葉使ってるんです
それから次の月で 行でヤマローカンチャイマンサデーヴァカン
このパテリー世界ということに何が入りますかと
ヤマローカンヤマローカンというのは死後の世界
誰がこの世界制覇するのかと
世界的って何や？と言うから言ったら
ただ地球のことだけじゃないんです
死後の世界も制覇する
それで止まらないんです
チャイマンサデーヴァカン
神々ももう神々の世界という概念も世の中にありますね
一応この世と天界という考え方もあるし
この世と山の世界があるという考え方もありました
インドでは すごいたくさん宗教ありましたから
同じヒンドゥ教の中で
その中で 山というのは死後ということで
山の意味は時間ということなんです
時間過ぎたところで行く世界なんです
だからヤマローカというので
こちらで生きている寿命は自分の時間で
それが終わったら時間が消えた世界に行かなくちゃいけない
ですからヤマローカというんですね
それは死後の世界って意味になるんですね
だからヒンドゥー教で
すごく古い お釈迦様の時代になってくると
結構なくなってなくなりすすの考え方なんですね
いわゆる聞いたことあるかどうかわかりませんだけど
このヴェーダ聖典という聖典があります
紀元前 3000年ぐらい古いと思ってるんです
一発でできたわけじゃないんですけど
ほんのわずかな一部はそれぐらい古くて
それからそれにいろいろ付け加えて付け加えて
今のヴェーダ聖典 4つあります
それを全部まとめたところで
おそらく  2000年からね
1500あたり 紀元前で終了したと思います
最初の芸なんかは 3000年ぐらい古いんじゃないかなと
そのヴェーダ聖典では
原始時代の人々の歌だからね
そちらではこのヤマローカという概念が出てくるので
人が死んで死後の世界にいるという 2次元的に考えているんです
それで自分の両親が死んだらもうあの世に行ったと
他界しましたと この他界がヤマローカなんです
それで じゃあそちらに行った人々にどうすればいいんでしょうかということで
もうかわいそうだから
なんとか親孝行しなくちゃいけないのではないかということで
いろいろお供えしてあげたりするっていう
お供えしてあげて 賛美歌を歌ってあげると
それでヤマローカではそのそれで
まあ何て言いますか 幸福にいられるというね
長生きできると そう考えていて
では次に出て それから時代
ちょっと時間経つと では息子が子供たちが供養しなかったらどうなるのかと
こちらから何て言いますかね
この なんかお金を送ることに
何て言いますか この 仕送り
みんなもう頭が良すぎてこの一般の日本語がわからないんですね
自分の子供がどこかで泊まって勉強してるんだったら
こちら仕送りするんです
で だからその場合も仕送りなんです
仕送りしなかったらどうなるのかというと
大変危険なことで死んじゃうんですね
この死は考えられなくなっちゃったんです
こちらでも死んで あの世で山の世界で生き続けて欲しかったのに
そちらで死んじゃったらどうなるのかとね
2番目の死っていうのはそういう疑問になって
それで引っかかったんです
そこで一旦ヴェーダ時代の思考体系が引っかかって止まっていて
それからまたいろいろいろいろいろいろ考え方をまた作り出しちゃったんです
戻るんじゃないかなと
戻ると言ったらどうやって戻るのかと
雨で戻るんです 雨が降ると火口で死んだ連中がもう仕送りがなくなった連中はみんなもうまた地球に降ってくるんだと
雨になって そこで植物に入り込んだりして
植物から動物に入り込んだりして
動物から人間に入ったりして
また生まれ変わっちゃうんだという考え方はゆっくり出てきたんです
すごいわかりやすいですからね
えーと そうなってきた時代もまた過ぎてからなんですね
お釈迦様の時代が時代になったのは
そういうふうにヒンドゥー教でも輪廻転生という考え方が出てきたんです
で 日本にあのすごい偉大なる仏教学者の中村先生とかね
いろいろ方々はやっぱりまあブッダはもうパクったと
そういう輪廻の概念を
ということは言ってますけど
まあ学者の方が言うんだからね
どうしようもないんですけど
私たちになんか言う立場がないんですからね
しかし 経典の中では ブッダは自分の考えで誰の考え方も借りてないぞということは
一応堂々と言ってるんです
初めて説法するんだと
いまだかつて聞いたことがない話だよと
人間も神々も誰も聞いたことがないんだというふうに
もうどこでもお釈迦もおっしゃってますけど
なかなか厳密に単語一つ一つ研究する先生方には
その文章は見つけてないんです
もし一箇所にあったら見つからなかったというならばね
これ一箇所じゃないんですよ
残念なことに 大体半分ぐらい経典の中に入ってます
ブッダのオリジナルだと
この教えは でも見つけてないんですよ
学者はその文章 例えば諸天法輪にもあるでしょうし
諸天法輪経でも やっぱり諸天法輪はもう認めないし
漢文にある で 漢文にありますから
漢文にある経典 すごい古いと言ってるんだから
だったらそこを見立てもあるでしょうに
いまだかつてない教えである
なんでそういうことをおっしゃるのかというと
このインドで研究したこのラーダ・クリシュナンのようなね
ヒンドゥー教の研究者たちが
まあ仏教はヒンドゥー教の一部ではないかというね
考え方を作り出して そこは尊敬したいんですね
だから学問の世界では
たとえ間違っても一生懸命認めてあげようというすごい努力なんです
で 反対意見出しちゃうと潰しちゃうんです
ラーダ・クリシュナンぐらいですね
そういうことを言っていたのは
ヨーロッパでも誰かが言ったんでしょうかね
そんなには言ってないんですけどね
ラーダ・クリシュナンという人はもうすごい学者なんです
とにかく で ヒンドゥー
インディアン・フィロソフィーというね
インドですごい本を書いていました
インドの大統領 前に ネールサンガ師匠がやっていた時はね
最初に大統領 まだガンディーさんを神様で尊敬すると考えた方もありましたからね
ガンディーは政治家で仏教なんかすごい嫌いんですね
で 自分が非暴力主義を謳っていたんだから
それブッダが言っているのでいたら立場が悪いんだからね
だからヒンドゥー教で非暴力主義はないんです
でも彼が マハトマ・ガンディーという人が
この一番怖い暴力は非暴力やということで
イギリス政府をね 植民地でしたからね
それに抵抗して対抗するために
この非暴力主義ということをしたんですね
おそらくイギリス軍隊がすごい武器を持ってるし
インド人には何もないしね
だからどう戦えばいいかと
喧嘩しちゃうと殺されるだけだから
そこら辺で思い浮かんだと思いますけどね
ヒンドゥー教は戦争の宗教であって
非暴力平和の宗教ではありません
非暴力主義っていうのはブッダオリジナルというわけでもない
もうジャイナ教にもありましたし
そこはもう明確にジャイナ教の人々もすごい非暴力主義を
徹底した非暴力主義を語っていて
ブッダがそこはちょっとやりすぎだと
あんた方はね 極端主義だと
極端っていうのは真理ではありませんと
ということで もうかなり論理的に理性的に調整したんですね
なぜならば ジャイナ教では冷たい水にも魂があるんだから飲んではいけないんです
水さえも飲んではいけないと言っちゃうと
これ自体が暴力主義なんです
だから植物に魂があるっていうのは当たり前でしょうに
生水にも魂があるんだから
取ってはあかんと 殺生してはいけないんだと
これが暴力主義なんです
結局は それで ではどうすればいいかというと
苦行すればいいんじゃないかということで
みんな飲まず食わず苦行していたんですね
結構人気はありますけどね
論理が崩れちゃうと結構人気はあります
で お釈迦様はこれが暴力主義だからね
もう生命に対する正しい慈しみということは
別な言葉で教えたんですね
それは誰もあまり認めないしね
例えば「嫌いな人も幸せでありますように」って何たる教えか
それはおかしいんじゃないかという態度は誰でも取る
嫌いな人は殺すもんでしょうと
それは世界にある愛っていうのはそんなレベルで
ブッダが自分をたとえ自分を殺されるだけでも慈しみでいなさいと
というブッダの非暴力主義なんですね
それは世界では認めていないんですけど
ブッダはそういうことを言うんです
だから私が言うのは 人が信じるか信じないかということではなくて
きちんと論理的で理性に基づいて誰にも攻撃反論できないようには語っている
それは認めるか認めないかということは
人に自由を与えている
あんたは気に入ったら認めるのはあなたの自由であると
認めなさいということを言っちゃうと
それがまた暴力主義になるんです
だからブッダの教えを否定することは
決して仏教侮辱でも何でもない
その人の自由なんです
そういうことで このヤマローカという単語の説明したんですが
インド世界で輪廻の概念はそんな程度で現れたものなんです
そんな程度と言ったって
もうどんな程度ですかね
もう忘れているでしょう
また繰り返すという時間はないんです
雨で降ってくるという話
それで雨で降ってきて
自分の父親が草の中に入ったとかね
もうジャガイモの中に入ったとかね
米の中に入ったとか言うと
また哲学的にまだぶつかっちゃうんですね
どこかに壁にぶつかるんですね
どうしようかと それで魂という概念が現れてきたんです
次のステージで 死んでも何か死なないものがあるんだと
それがヤマローカに行って
そこで栄養が仕送りなくなっちゃうと
また雨に乗って降ってくるんですけど
この魂がアイデンティティがあって
これは変わらないんだと
そういう思考体系がある
それで宗教っていうのは商売だから
一応 それでこの仕送りを来る金融機関が成り立ったんです
それがバラモン人なんです
彼らがもう法律的にこの仕送りする人々なんです
だから 息子が勝手に何かご飯炊いて
何か幼いものを作って
これは父親に仕送りしますと言っても
それはいかないんだと
ちゃんと今はだったら銀行で振り込まないと
世界中どんな人にも国お金を送られるでしょうに
その人の口座番号を知っているならば
こちらの銀行だったら通していける
それは合法的 もしこそっと他の方法で送っちゃうと
これは違法なんです そういうことでバラモン人なんですよ
この金融機関は だからバラモン人に頼んで息子が仕送りさせなくちゃいけない
それはヤーガということで
ヤーガは日本語で何言ったっけ
供養  他の単語ないんですか？ 犠牲
拙者  生贄  うん  日本語で哲学を語るのはものすごく難しいんですね
単語がないんですからね
で yagaっていうことはritual sacrificeということなんです
区儀ですか？ 区儀 区儀の漢字は
備えるっていうのと儀式の儀ですね
備えるという漢字に儀式というの
儀式の儀を入れたら区儀と読めるんでしたそうです
普通の方儀ではありません
で そこはこの区儀もものすごいたくさん種類がありまして
このceremony, sacrifice, ritualという英語だったら単語大体見つかります
また カトリックになってくると
またいろいろわけのわからない単語がたくさんありますけどね
私も覚えてないんですが
見たらわかりますけど liturgy
ということもあるしね
まあカトリック教だったら皆様すごい馴染みがあると思いますけどね liturgy
っていうのはもう神様にも賛嘆して歌いまくることなんです
皆様大事にする神様ってのはすごい歌が好きみたいです
だから教会でよく賛美歌を歌うんです
それでメッサやることは
これはliturgyなんですね
それもヒンドゥー教でやってることと同じやり方
同じことなんです それでこのバラモン人がこの
この仕送りを送る金融機関で
それでその人々は自分の収入のためにその料金は取る
手数料は それどうなったか
手数料の方がちょっと重いんだったら
結構気合入れてやる 手数料が少ないんだったら
もういい加減にやる そこでバラモン人がそれで自分たちの商売のためにシステムを作ったんですね
区儀の仕方ということで
複数の区儀を開発して
複数のものすごいハチャメチャなやり方をいろいろ開発して
それから もしそれは自分のカースト以外の人を勉強して
同じ歌を歌って区儀をしちゃうと
そうするとこれ商売としてはちょっと邪魔なんですね
だから他人に禁止しちゃったんです
ヴェーダを読むことも勉強することも
バラモン人以外は で これだけではちょっと安全対策は足らないんです
それで たとえバラモン人であろうとも
発音は一つも間違わす
長い文句を言わなくちゃいけないんだと
例えば １時間かけてずっと賛美歌を歌っても
どこかで間違っちゃうと全部無効になるんだと
いうということで言っちゃうと
これ大変なことなんです
堂々と言うんです それで間違えますよと
この仕送りは行かないんだと
例えば銀行口座の 1つの番
数字変えたってももうダメだから
私も一回ひどい目に遭いましたからね
誰かが自分の名前と口座番号をこちらに送ってくれて
その通りに送ったんですと
向こうの銀行は断るんです
お金払うな で お金もう銀行払ってくれないんだと
どういうこと？って言いますよ
私に文句言ったって意味がないでしょうに
あんた書いてくれた通りに送ってやったんだと
だけど とにかくお金がもうなくなっちゃいますからね
銀行がパクっちゃいますから
そのお金を で また事件決まりま-- もう契約の場合はね
何ヶ月とかいないとかっていうこともあるし
で それで道を まあ今家に行って
自分のこの銀行の何とか本あるでしょ
あれ 何て言いますか  通帳
通帳持ってこいと 持ってきて
通帳を開けて名前読み上げなさいと
一つ一つ で それで読み上げてもらって
番号も読み上げてもらって
二 三回それまた試してみて
はいわかりましたと もう一度日本の銀行にお金払って手数料を払って
あの口座前送ったものを訂正してくださいと
訂正メッセージを送るだけなんですよ
二 三秒の仕事です 送金した番号を入れて
訂正はこれですと それだけ
結構お金かかります それに
だから大変ですよ そんなシステムをバラモン人が昔作ったんです
この区切りで唱えるお経文言をほんのちょっとでも間違ったらもう
もういかないんだと そうするとこの供養したいと思っている人々っていうのはかなり大変なんです
精神的には で バラモン人はもうこの人々のお布施は足らんとかなんとか思っちゃうとね
お布施とは言わないんですけど
別な言葉使いますけど
払うお金 手数料が足らないと思っちゃうと
もういい加減やる可能性はあります
そうなっちゃうと せっかく自分の父親に母親にこの供養が行かなくなっちゃうんです
それでそんな法律を作ったのはいいんだけど
バラモン人が 結局そこは自分たちには大変なことになっちゃったんです
バラモン人の連中が一人前になるということは
もう大変な作業なんです
そこら中にいるどんなバラモン人にも
じゃあ私は区切りを 儀式をやってあげますということはできなくなっちゃったんです
それでバラモン人が小さな子供の時からもヴェーダ聖典の発声練習をするんです
微妙にでも間違わないようにと
何十年もかかります まあ神はなかった時代でしょうし
あの膨大なテキストを全部暗記していただけではダメです
これ明確に発音を正す方法でやらなくては
それは伝統 今もありますよ
まあ私たちにとっても同じ文化だから
発音を正す方法というのは結構あります
だから仏教の場合でも同じこと
正しく発音しないと意味が通じないということで
相手にね 発音訓練はします
それにはまあすごい工夫して詩を作るんです
日本語にでもあります
なんとか何とか単語というんですけど
えらい発音しにくい文章を作ったりしてね
それはガチャガチャガチャガチャガチャガチャガチャ
繰り返し繰り返し繰り返し言って
舌の周り 喉の周り 唇の周りを訓練するんです
日本語だったら何て言葉で言うんだっけ
早口言葉？ 生麦 生卵  そうそう
生卵なんとか何とか言ったりしてね
あれ難しいんですよ アナウンサーになる人々は必ずやらなくちゃいけない
で それで生麦生卵というのは別に
もう我々から見ればあまりチョロいんです
あんなのは 節を覚えなくちゃいけないんです
その各芸にそれなりのちゃんだしやらいろいろありますからね
どこで切ってどこで伸ばして
どこで気を吸ってやるのかという
そういう微妙な決まりがあるんです
キャーキャーキャーキャーで言っただけでは正しくないんです
それに合わせたいろんな詩はいっぱいあります
サンスクリット 僕らはもうサンスクリット語でやるんですよ
で 詩をやって訓練して
それから文章読み上げて訓練するんです
大体出家したら 最初の学問というのはそこら辺です
まず発音の訓練 そこから始まるんです
昔 覚えた芸いろいろありましたけどね
今はもうとっくに忘れちゃった
まあそういうことだから
その発音をすごい気にする文化なんです
しかし イントネーションはないんだからね
なかなか中国語は勉強できないんですよ
我々は音で勝負だから
中国人が音じゃなくてイントネーションの勝負なんですね
子だけ 子 子だけ覚えてれば中国語全部できますけど
これいろいろもうやり方だから
もうこれがなかなか我々の耳では取れないんですね
それでこのバラモン人がこの供養文化を作ったんです
供養文化をどんどん開発しちゃって
何を供養すれば向こうに何がもらえますか？と
そこまで発展させちゃうんですね
そこでこの死んだ連中だけじゃなくて
それはまあ 父の世界というピートルローカという言葉があるんで
専門用語ですけども このピートルローカからペータという言葉がサンスクリット語以外の言語になってきて
ペータという場合は父という意味じゃなくて
出て行ったという意味になるんです
だから結局はサンスクリット語に後から入る言葉やと思いますけどね
去った人々の世界ということでペータと
日本が仏教でこの餓鬼というのはこのペータなんですね
餓鬼道というのはこのペータローカと呼んでいるパーリ語で
そうやってこの同じ単語を使っているんだから
学者がもうえらい勘違いするんです
それはあちらかのピートルローカのあれを取っているんだとかね
もうむちゃくちゃですね
インド哲学をやっている人々の考え方というのは
いろいろ儀式 文化を作って
それからこの亡くなった先祖だけじゃなくて
生きている人々にもその力が入ってくるんだということで
現世利益のためにもまた区々のシステムができてしまったんです
現世利益で何を狙っているのかと
商売繁盛か 家庭なんとかとかね
家庭円満か 無病息災か
それぞれに合わせて区々あります
インドでは当時の社会で
特に金持ちにしかできなくなっちゃったんです
結局は 金持ちといえば無茶の商人か王様かぐらいなもんなんだ
だから王様になってくると
もう戦略することやら
戦争で戦って勝つことやら
自分の領土を広げることやら
そういう御利益が入ってくるんです
それでそういう区々あるんです
領土を広げ これこれやれば領土は広げられますと
これこれやれば戦争で勝ちますとかね
そういう世界になってしまったんです
それがだいたい完成された時期でブッダが現れたんです
しかし ブッダはひとかけらもバラモン人の考え方を取らなかったんです
参考に単語 もし同じ言語を使っていたんだから
言語を使う時でも バラモン人以外の人々が使っている言語を使ったりする
だからニッバーナ 涅槃という何かヒンドゥー教でどこにもないんです
ヒンドゥー教は仏教からパクっちゃったんです
サマーディとかそんなのないんです
なかったんです 瞑想しないバラモン人が
反対でしたし しかし このこんな人を搾取するんだから
ある一部のグループが
それに戦って立ち上がった人々がすっばいいたんです
ほとんどクシャトリヤ職から上がったんです
なんで我々は王家の人々なのに
軍人なのに こいつらに頭下げなくちゃあかんかと
金持って逃げるだけではないかと
ということで クシャトリヤの人々の間で別な宗教が現れたんです
ジャイナ教は一つ 今はインドにあります
それクシャトリヤの人々が作った宗教の一つなんです
はい まああんまり家は家柄は考えなかったんですけどね
まあバラモン人の中でもこの連中と一緒にいたくないという人々いくらでも出ますからね
あの父親の話はもう嫌やと
あの性格は大嫌いやと言って
もう自分が出ていくぞという風にね
人々がいましたから まあいろいろ別な宗教はたくさん現れたんです
みんなこのバラモン文化には一応抵抗して
だいたい日本語のテキストでは気にしていないポイントがありまして
仏教はこの釈族のというところはすごい強調するんです
釈迦牟尼仏陀と日本語でも言うんです
このシャーキヤであることは極力強調するんです
カースト 家を それはクシャトリヤ職が作った宗教ということは強調したいんです
歴史的に あんたらあなた方とは何の関係もないんだと
反対だよと というこの歴史的な背景の影響なんです
お釈迦様はカースト制度を否定しているんだからね
全く認めないんだから
そんなことを言う必要はないでしょうに
しかし 歴史背景では言わなくちゃいけなくなった
それでシャカ シャ クシャトリヤ職であろうとも
ものすごい純血統だと
血統を考えちゃうと バラモン人よりははるかに優れているんだと
純粋な血統で バラモン人よりも格が上やということは徹底的に強調する
強調してからカースト制度っていうのをくっつけてるんです
かなりすごい複雑なもう歴史なんですよ
まあ皆様にはあまり関係ない学問的な話ですけどね
まあとにかく一つ一つ単語にはすごい歴史があるんです
ですから このヤマローカンという言葉にもすごい長い歴史があるんです
そちらなんでサデーワカン入れたかというと
これまたすごい歴史があるんです
今言った歴史は このヤマローカンという歴史なんです
死後の世界という それで文化によってヤマという
まあ死後の世界にも神様がいると
これヤマという神様なんですね
日本にもいます その人は
閻魔大王っていうのは
閻魔っていうのはヤマという意味なの
言葉なんです 音なんです
悪魔の魔じゃないんです
閻魔 それはヤマなんです
漢字で山と書けるのにね
まあ閻魔にしてるんです
わかりません なんだか
閻魔さんが まあどこにいるんですかね
私はあまり住所を知らんだけどね
で パーリ経典でヤマラージャとかね
という言葉 いくつかのところには出ています
それも当時の人々は この
これまたバラモン人と違った
また別な宗教のグループで考えたことなんですね
審判する神様がいるんだぞとかね
天国に行かせるか地獄に送るかというね
その審判する神が閻魔大王なんですね
お釈迦様はただ文学的な表現で使ったんですけど
これは大乗仏教になるとえらい本気で真面目で
実際にそういう神がいるぞということに
また遠い昔の あの インドの宗教に戻ってしまったんです
まあ確かにお釈迦様は閻魔王という言葉を使ってます
ヤマラージャということを使ってます
それは単なる文学なんです
これが本気で文字通りに
大乗仏教は単語を文字通りに取ってしまったことで
ヒンドゥー教になってしまったんです
それがまたお釈迦様に文句を言うんですね
ブッダが全部パクったと
あんた方でしょって私が言いたいんですけど
もうあべこべに考えているのは
だからヤマラージャという言葉あるんだから
やっぱりこれはなんとかなんとかテキストにあるんじゃないかとかね
あるのはありますよ お釈迦様は本当にその意味で取ったのかと
その意味で取っているわけじゃないんです
それで なんでサデーワカン
神々も入ってる世界と言ったのかというと
これまたこのヴェーダ聖典にまた因縁話があるんです
インドを占領したこのアーリア民族っていうのはね
もう もういい加減な民族で
人殺すことしか何も知らない
で その人々はずっとどこから来た連中かさっぱりわからないんですね
もう世界でもう結構広げてはいるんですけど
時々考えたりもしますね
学者が このアーリア民族の初めはどこかなとかね
もうどこでしょうかね
私はわかりませんだけど
一応イランという国だけはありますよ
その人も同じ民族で そこからあっちこっちヨーロッパやらね
もうインドやらあちらこちらで広げていった可能性はあって
とにかく戦争してもう国を取るんです
インドにも入って これすごい昔話でね
もう紀元三千年の時代の話でね
それでモヘンジョダロという古代文明も全部もう破壊してしまっちゃって
自分たちの文明を作った
築いてしまったんです
その時の時はこの戦争に行くんだから
自分たちを誰かが守っているんだということで神々だったんです
だから世界と神の世界という考え方は
またそういうアーリアの連中が持っていたんです
神は誰かというと はっきりわからないんですよ
当時でも 神は誰ですかと言っちゃうと
もう何とか言うんですよ
雨の神やと 雷の神やとかね
もう空の神やと 地球も大地も神ですよとも言っていたし
いろいろいろいろごちゃごちゃごちゃごちゃごちゃごちゃで
そこで世界二つあるんですよ
我々の世界と死後の世界と
我々の世界と神々の世界と
この我々の世界と神々の世界っていうのは
このギリシアの神々の世界にも似ている
だから お釈迦様のこの言葉にこれが入っているんだから
これ誰の考え方もパクってるわけじゃないんです
そんなのはどうでもいいんだから
全部まとめて言う話なんです
この地球は誰が制覇するのかと
この世界は誰が制覇するのか
世界と言ったっても全部入ってるんだよと
山の世界であろうが 神々も含む世界だが
全部世界で見たら誰が一切制覇するのかということで
今まである一切の宗教に対してすごい攻撃的な質問なんです
誰かの宗教の中に入っているわけじゃなくて
今まである一切の宗教より優れている境地のことを言ってるんです
そういうことで だから仏教になってくると意味はまたすごく分かりやすくて
誰が全ての生命乗り越えて勝利者になるのかという意味になるんです
ただ生きているだけでは
生きているだけでは意味がなくてね
生きているということは乗り越えて勝利者になったと
それが誰がするのかという質問ですね
コーダンマパダンすでにした三行目
ダンマパダンっていうのはダンマパダですね
真理の言葉なんですね
真理の言葉っていうのは
科学的な数学的な方程式みたいなもので
もうぴったしあって もう誰にも変えることはできない
例えば三角形の面積はどうやって取るのかというと
これはもう決まっているでしょうね
日本語では私分かりませんだけど
一応 底辺かける高さの半分ですね
これは方程式で もうこれは違いますよということはできません
ダンマパダといえば そういう風な this Okkyo 文句になるんです
だから this Okkyo 文句だから全部しっかりした言葉なんです
それがそれにも歴史がありまして,このバラモンの宗教にあるマントラという言葉があります
ヴェーダは歌になる歌でしたけど
後でマントラにしたんですね
マントラといえば この
なんかちょっとしたこの不可思議な力が入っている言葉であると
だから言葉そのままでなければいけませんと
だから言葉に力があるかと
それがもうミスティカルな力で
ミスティックって何でしたっけ？神秘的な普通の力ではないんだと
人の心変える 運命変える力があるんだと
いうことで このもうものすごいもうバラモン人が知らない昔からある聖典だからね
それはあれほど自分たちで自分の首を絞めるような法律を作っちゃったんだから
むちゃ勉強しなくちゃいけない
それでヴェーダ聖典がマントラになった
ヴェーダマントラということになってしまったんです
マントラっていうのはサンスクリット語の発音でマントラなんですね
で 日本語ではマントラと言えば呪文ということになりますけどね
呪文と同じ意味だと思います
それでマントラは変えられない
お釈迦様から見れば馬鹿馬鹿しいもいいところで
お釈迦様が世界で初めて変えられない言葉を作って見せたんです
真理の言葉 それは全部ブッダオリジナルなんです
だからヴェーダ聖典のマントラという考え方は頭にあったんですよ
マントラっていうのは絶対誰にも変えることのできない神の言葉であるという
それこそが真理だと でもお釈迦様は違うと
違うよと 真理が私が初めて語ってみせるそうと
誰にも変えることできないんだよと
できるならやってみろと
これはもうブッダ以外誰にもできることじゃないんです
ごく普通な言葉 アッパマードーアマタパダンとかナヒヴェーレーナヴェーラーニとか
イマダニディティタ人間は誰一人見ません
怒りは怒り ナヒヴェーレーナ怒りは怒りでは消えませんよとか
慈しみによってのみ消えるんだよとか
すべて方程式みたいな単語なんです
もう変えることも訂正することも直すことも誰にもできない
それでマントラという言葉は使わない
けなす 何の丁重もなくけなちゃうんです
その代わりにダンマパダという言葉
ダンマという言葉を使っています
そういうダンマパダなんです
そちらにも歴史があるんです
だからコーイマンダンマパダン sudesitan sudesitan
というのは見事にぴったし語っている
ダンマパダ この法律ですね
真理の言葉 クサロープッパミバパチェッティ
クサローっていうのは上手な
上手な人 頭のいい人 巧みな人っていうことで
才能ある人 プッパンイワ花のごとく咲く
それが誰でしょうかと
誰が花を咲かせてみせるのかと
この真理の言葉を 真理の言葉という種に花を咲かすことは誰にできるのかと
だから これ文学的な詩でもありながら
すごい難しいことを言っているんです
で 花を咲くという表現というのは
例えば種があっても それを植えて水をあげてきちんと花を咲かせるという意味なんですね
それが誰にもできるわけじゃないんですよ
そこで お釈迦様の言葉っていうのは
ある真理を発見する種なんです
方程式なんですよ そこは誰が実行して結果出すのかと
科学と私は科学的というのはそういう至る所に科学的という科学性が入っているんです
科学者がいろいろ方式やらね
いろいろ真理を発見する
発見しただけで意味がないんですよ
本当にそうなのかと 至る所で研究して証明しなくちゃいけないんです
例えば地球には引力があると
それを計算すればどれぐらいでしょうかと
もしその計算が正しければ
逆のエネルギーを使うと地球の引力から物体が逃げるはずなんです
そこで引力にはいろいろごちゃごちゃな計算式がありますよ
引力によるこの力が やっぱりどれぐらいその物体にエネルギーを与えれば地球の引力から離れますかと
それも計算できる そんなこと計算できたって本当なのかという問題が出てくるんです
それでみんなもうご飯食べるお金もなんで人の金を取ったりして
膨大なお金がかかってロケット作ったり
衛星作ったりして飛ばしてみるでしょ
それで見事に衛星が行っちゃいますからね
なるほど 計算が合っているということになるんです
計算微妙に間違っちゃうと行かないんです
だから地球に引力があるんだぞとかね
物体にこれぐらいエネルギーを与えれば
これは地球から飛んでいくぞとぐらい我々にも言えるんですけど
ロケットは作れないんですよ
だからこの方程式があっても
上手な人が 巧みな人がそれを実行して花を咲かせてみせる
[音楽]だからブッダの言葉は真理ですが
実行してこの通りだと花を咲かせて見せなくちゃいけないんです
それでお釈迦様が言うのは
この勝利者になるんだと
一切智者になるんだと
完全に苦しみはなくなるんだと
平安解脱を得られるんだと
すべての疑が消えるんだと
これをやってみれば と言うならば
本当なのかと試してみなくちゃいけないんですね
そこはこの質問で この偈で成り立っています
一応それぐらい意味があると私は言いますけど
皆様ないと思うならば
それはそれでよろしいんです
で 日本語で書いてないんだからないだろうと
と思う可能性もあります
この四十四の意味はその意味なんです
こうイマンパテリンリジェッサティヤマローカンチャイマンサデーワカンコーダンマパダンソデーシタンクサロープッパニワパチェッサティ
[読経]